Chúng tôi như gì là người mùa tham đệch.
Chính quyết nguyên này vẫn đoàn kết và tiếp tục kếm soát em khai miếng sau khi tổn điplas
Mà đồ bý mý bắt giữ.
Chông bối cảnh ra các đăng đổ mắt bất đệch chính trị lần nhất trong nhật kì.
Tại đồ carcass, mũ trường nó vụ đi ốt đà đồ, ca bè lâu đề bố.
Chỉ có mũ tổn thống là điplas Mà đồ, kêu gọi lực cầm quyền dưới đoàn kết
và ca buộc mỷ tiền hành bắt cóc tổn thống bắt của nhân.
Bố chưởng của phòng là đi mẹ part 3 nấu cho biết, cơ lộng của chàng đại được cái khóa tình nhằm bảo vệ chục về phu ra.
Tổn thống ca, vừa như thế là, hiện chào về điều hành tạo thời cho mỡ đều xíu của Newcast.
Về đồng thời gian chức của chức, tổn mỡ.
Mà khẳng đệch, ông Mà đồ, mất là tổn thống phật pháp.
Đồng thời bắt bỏ tình mũ tự Washington rằng,
carcass sẽ hợp đa với mìi.
Tình hình trong nước, vừa như thế là, nhìn chục dên ám, hơi các cuộc tổn hành của mỡ chính vụ.
Hãy video dễn ra hành trẻ, phát động xin hoặc tại như thành phố vật tiếp diễn,
sông tâm li lòng ngại bao trồm khi người dân tích chục nguyêu phẩm và chờ đợi gặp dịch viện tiếp theo.
Chính quyền với Newcast, các vùng mỡ ít tìm cách chiếm đoạn tàng quyền lập miệt là dổn mò.
Tại Mỹ, Washington rằng, ông Mà đồ, đàn bị dạm tại Newcast để chờ hậu ra với các cậu buộc lên quan đến mặt với
tổn thống thống đúng là trông tình bố, mỡ ít sẽ ek yp ra với Newcast,
sông chưa như là phạm vi và thử hạn gần dự.